und ich möchte mit einem thema staaten
was mich heute besonders bewegt hat es
geht um den menschenrechtsaktivisten
rossmann kavala der sich erdreistet hat
etwas zum taxi protest zu sagen der als
oppositioneller sozusagen gegen erdogan
stand dann wurde er festgenommen bereits
zum zweiten mal und ist jetzt seit vier
jahren in haft ohne verurteilung und der
deutsche botschafter hat dann darauf
hingewiesen wie auch andere botschafter
dass das doch nicht so ganz in ordnung
ist und was machte erdogan er rastet
komplett aus und droht damit unseren
botschafter wie auch andere auszuweisen
für mich zeigt dass erneut dass mit
diesem präsidenten alles möglich ist in
der türkei und ich hoffe dass wir uns
nicht einschüchtern lassen denn das ist
was momentan passiert ich habe bislang
keine antwort der bundesregierung gehört
keine antwort echte antwort des
außenministers darauf tatsächlich hat
man offenbar immer noch angst dass
erdogan und zum beispiel flüchtlinge
geschehen könnte
weil ich teil ihrer these dass man die
menschenrechte nicht mit füßen treten
darf dass man darauf stehen muss mein
geschätzter welt kollege dennis user
selber in türkischer haft gesessen da
wurde die pressefreiheit einfach
verletzt und trotzdem möchte ich ein
bisschen um verständnis wir haben auch
für die zwänge von realpolitik und
diplomatie manchmal muss man auch hinter
den kulissen vielleicht was erwirken als
politiker und es kann sich auch
kontraproduktiv auswirken in so einer
phase dann öffentlich zu äußern
realpolitik finde hier so ein bisschen
das unwort der letzten jahre nicht mehr
anschauen wie oft um realpolitik damit
begründet wird dass man nicht auf steht
dass man nichts sagt dass man erdogan
zum beispiel einfach machen lässt es ist
ja ganz sicher so dass die botschafter
nicht auf eigene rechnung sich
öffentlich geäußert haben in der türkei
sondern dass sie ihre regierungen hinter
sich gewusst haben auch die
regierungschefs und wenn er jetzt droht
sie aus zu werfen ist die neu
auszuweisen ist die nächste phase
gekommen wo die regierungschefs sich
miteinander öffentlich äußern müssen
unter stetig erdogan das wird schwere
konsequenzen für die kanzlerin könnte
das noch machen zum sitzen heute beim eu
gipfel zusammen das sind ja nun 10
miteinander verbündete staaten ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob es alle eu staaten sind
das habe ich jetzt nicht mal
nachgeschaut aber jedenfalls die meisten
sind es die können doch miteinander 10
regierungschefs sagen das ist unsere
haltung und wir werden ihn verteidigen
und wir werden auch unsere botschafter
verlängern das kann ihnen natürlich
trotzdem dazu bringen die botschafter
auszuweisen dann müssen die regierung
handeln caroline buß brach wie sehen sie
das ich falls ich wollte gerade genau
daran anknüpfen ich glaube selbst wenn
genau das getan wird und wenn wir auch
diese herangehensweise passieren ich
glaube nicht dass denen das besonders
interessieren wird ich glaube wenn wir
uns hier empören und versuchen zu
moralisieren und unsere werte zu
exportieren machen wir sowieso sehr
gerne geht ja auch für china ich glaub
er drüben in der türkei da fällt in
welcher - und das wird ihn einfach nicht
jucken und das ist ich glaube der weg
dahin ist noch sehr sehr weit außen
politischer überzeugung und wir werden
unsere reigen aber unsere
erwartungshaltung muss realistisch sein
und so allerwichtigste dass eben auf
internationaler bühne zu machen
zusammenzustehen jetzt ist ja auch ein
signal nach außen ich befürchte mehr als
eine signalwirkung wird es nicht sein
also ich bin der meinung dass wir erst
mal anfangen müssen über unsere
drecksarbeit nachzudenken die wehr
erdogan machen lassen und das ist das
thema flüchtlinge sind ich finde ein
bisschen schwierig wie wir überhaupt
noch den starken deutschen mann machen
können während wir den shady die mit der
türkei haben also das ist für mich
eigentlich wieder ein fall wo ich sage
darüber muss man das abkommen habe was
er nicht so wirklich funktioniert wenn
man sagen wo wir eigentlich schon ich
meine das ist für mich schon versagen
von frau merkel sie hat ja eigentlich
einfach erdogan ihre arbeit machen aber
das ist drecksarbeit das hier ist sich
da nicht was da getan wenn es ist nie
das macht es leichter licht das ist
goldrichtig dass die flüchtlinge in der
nähe ihrer heimat bleiben damit sie
jederzeit zurückkehren können man muss
moment wenig den flüchtlingen wir hätten
genauso schauen es nach sind diese
politisch so weit ist politisch richtig
gewesen das geld fließt ja auch ein
flüchtlingslager
und in die ausbildung von
flüchtlingskindern und so weiter das
fließt ja nicht in die tasche von herrn
erdogan das wird ja überprüft was mit
dem geld passiert das ist einfach ein
leben das tun sich aber drecksarbeit tut
mir leid ich bin ist
da sind wir bei unserer tracks aber beim
thema flüchtlinge sind müssen wir
vielleicht über einen anderen diktator
noch sprechen jan willem alexander
lukaschenko der die flüchtlinge richtung
polen schickt jetzt wird diskutiert
heute auch in brüssel über eine mauer
die dort entsteht wie ist das zu sehen
ja eine mauer da denkt man natürlich
sofort an trump und ich glaube es zeigt
einmal mehr wenn wir vertikal die türkei
sprechen dass wir in gewisser weise da
in so einer geiselhaft sind dort in
einem moralischen und praktischen
dilemma aus dem ich jetzt auch nicht so
einfach einen ausweg beschreiben könnte
wir sitzen hier im warmen studio antrieb
haben die polen recht genauso wie die
türken dass sie sagen so kann man nicht
mit uns umspringen nicht so nicht sagen
nun hat sich der stadt hat er an der an
der grenze im mittelmeer hat sich viel
geändert also die griechen schicken
aufgebrachte flüchtlingsboote zurück sie
schieben sie zurück was sie eigentlich
nicht dürfen widerspricht euro gehalt
und widerspricht europäischem recht akku
keiner so genau hin weil alle wissen das
müssen wir irgendwie pragmatisch lösen
die werden zurückgebracht in die türkei
das gelingt nicht bei allen schiffen
aber jedenfalls bei sehr vielen gelingt
es wir müssen uns wir sind in dem die er
macht keine drecksarbeit für uns der
versucht uns zu erpressen herr goren das
ist
keine arbeit für
uns ist einem nachwuchsarbeit er hat die
flüchtlinge gegen europa geschickt um
uns zu erpressen die vielen schiffe die
im jahr 15 16 über das mittelmeer
gekommen sind sind von der türkei
losgeschickt worden die sind in bussen
an die küste gefahren worden weil
erdogan einen hebel gegen europa und
sich mit dreckigem ein um es noch einmal
zu sagen wir hätten sagen müssen wie
viele wir nehmen können wie viel ich
frau merkel dazu gemacht wir nehmen alle
dann hat sie in dir gemacht
mal ganz kurz erleben heute sicherlich
die bilder auch eben aus polen gesehen
haben caros doch was ist da weil es ist
ja eigentlich ähnlicher fall wie in der
türkei da geht es jetzt darum man
braucht vielleicht ein abkommen aber wie
wir damals erlebt haben auf der
balkanroute da haben ja die mazedonier
zusammen mit den griechen auch einfach
angefangen zaun zu bauen damals noch was
ist das richtige an der polnischen sind
ja das wahrscheinlich genau nicht aber
hansson ein aber so wie es auch gratis
kotiert haben da jetzt sei die pauschale
lösung auf den tisch zu legen wenn jetzt
sehr viel zu kurz gegriffen es ist mir
dürfen nicht unterschätzen was das auch
wieder im internationalen raum in europa
bedeutet welche signale auch damit
ausgesandt werden auch was wieder für
deutschland heißt das einfach mal zu
ende zu denken gerade auf die folgen
wenn mein unfassbare migrationsdruck
draußen in der welt mir haben wir dir
das sowieso viel zu wenig thematisiert
und wenn wahrscheinlich gar nicht an dem
punkt an dem wir jetzt sind stichwort
bundestag haben all das was in den
letzten monaten passiert ist und wie man
an den man sich lief ja an sich die
finger verbrennen hast du ja warum ist
das so gute frage ich würde mir wünschen
dass genau das auch so flog aber das
sind doch heute ganz andere flüchtlinge
als die die wir 2015 erlebt haben die
heute kommen im flugzeug aus dem irak
und aus syrien hierher geflohen irak ist
nicht mehr ein das kann ich ja und die
kriegen eine ausreisegenehmigung ihrer
regierung das sind auch wohlhabende
flüchten müssen den flug bezahlen
darlegen familien zusammen und die
finanzieren die schlepper und schleuser
und fliegen jedenfalls nach minsk das
ist ja eine art von entschuldigung das
im begriff verwende von luxus flüchtling
gemessen an den elenden die sich vor ein
paar jahren zu es in der welt
wir müssen los wir müssen die wahrheit
sagen und gehofft habe ich von
flüchtlingen heucheln wenn es gar keine
sind das sind überwiegend junge männer
die hier arbeiten wollen in europa
kommen um ihr glück zu machen nicht nur
aber die seiten das häufig dinge nennen
da können wir dann viele bürger sie
haben ende den usa als korrespondent
auch erlebt was sozusagen an der grenze
zu mexiko passiert wie liest das im
vergleich der umgang der usa und auch
die diskussion dort im vergleich zu
europa also gerade die aktuelle
situation ist sehr interessant denn es
sind ja jetzt mehr illegale einwanderer
aufgegriffen worden als je zuvor 200.000
jetzt in kürzester zeit und joe biden
war mit dem versprechen angetreten die
grenzpolitik humaner zu gestalten und es
gelingt ihm nicht erhält jetzt fest an
einem einwanderungs im paragrafen von
donald trump der besagt dass man auch
ungeprüft wieder die leute abschieben
kann dafür kriegt das natürlich heftig
ins gesicht jetzt von den demokraten und
die republikaner kritisieren ihn
trotzdem weil er die situation einer
grenze nicht im griff hat er kriegt also
feuer von beiden seiten zeigt wieder wie
schwer das ist die situation der hre
sehr spannender punkt
[Musik]